the question lies with Kamara Usman what
version are we gonna get and I don't
think he has many left either one or two
Max wouldn't be surprised for your times
off this fight I have huge question
marks Corner Usman that's why I would
probably lean towards Leon Edwards win
this fight which I think is completely
against the oddsmakers the other experts
out there again not referring to myself
as an expert the other MMA analysts out
there I'm not sure how many pick in Leon
Edwards but Leon Edwards in his backyard
you can bet on Leon which I kind of
leaning towards you're you're been
against the greatest ever do it his
pride his legacy is on the line that's
asking a lot for leonos to beat Kumar
Usman tomorrow knows something we don't
know where he's this is the last one he
didn't get one hell of a version of
Kumar loose men